c'est un endroit mystérieux aux portes
de
Besançon un château discret cerné par
les arbres et des douves qu'on
franchissait par cet ancien pont Levie
une vieille bâtisse qui dissimule bien
des trésors comme cette petite chapelle
néogothique élevée en
1861 on aimerait vraiment ouvrir et
faire découvrir ce lieu après hélas ben
là on voit que le plafond est en train
de de de tomber tout doucement on a le
le par quet qui est mangé à l'entrée de
la chapelle et qui se dégrade à toute
vitesse donc là il y a des gros travaux
à à faire et rapidement hélas pour pas
que que que tout se perde plus
incroyable encore sous le parc à
l'anglaise c'est qu' voûé du 13e siècle
celle de l'ancien prieuré où les moines
gardaient leur vin et un grand secret il
y aurait un souterrain qui part depuis
la cave et qui va rejoindre en fait le
château de mafauucon puisqueà l'époque
les deux
seigneueries de Beaupré et de mafauuccon
étaient rattaché alors vous voyez ici
l'ancienne entrée de ce tunnel
souterrain il y a 2 ans Périne et
François ont eu littéralement le coup de
foudre pour le domaine de Beaupré on est
tombé amoureux du lieu et on a signé en
3 jours voilà et maintenant on réfléchit
à ce qu'on fait avec tout ça tout ça
c'est le passé du lieu avec sa galerie
de personnag historique grandvel a
reposé ici avant ses funérailles mais
jeevent y a installé sa manufacture
d'horlogerie de goule il y a même passer
une nuit de quoi pousser le couple à
écrire une nouvelle page et bâtir tout
un projet de restauration tous se
concentrer d'histoire dans un même
lieu moi ça m'a passionné ça nous a
passionné pour finaliser tel que le
projet a été réfléchi il faudrait encore
200 million2 à peu près d'euros pour
pouvoir faire le pro initial ça va se
faire mais progressivement étape par
étape on sa ça prendra combien de temps
oh là là je pense que là on a signé pour
pour toute une vie soutenu par la Région
le Grand Besançon il souhaite ouvrir CIN
chambres d'ôes et un git déjà reconnu
par la Fondation du Patrimoine les
nouveaux propriétaires espèrent aussi
une inscription au Monument Historique
l'histoire ne fait que
commencer